The Numerous Bodies Recently Found in Ben
Franklin’s Basement
For eighteen years, Ben Franklin, the great
American inventor, diplomat, and signer of
the Declaration of Independence, was a tenant
in a beautiful four story Georgian house at
36 Craven Street in London, mere blocks from
the River Thames.
As ambassador from the colonies, he entertained,
lived, and even allowed other intellectuals
of the time to stay at the house while he
lived there from 1757 through 1775.
Nearly 225 years later, as the house stood
dilapidated and on the brink of collapse,
a group called “Friends of Benjamin Franklin
House” decided to renovate the building
and turn it into a museum honoring one of
America’s founding fathers.
Work commenced, but only a month into the
renovation, a construction worker named Jim
Field made a startling discovery in the windowless
basement: A human thigh bone sticking out
of a dirt-filled pit.
After further excavation (with the help of
the London police), more than 1200 other bones
– all dated from about 200 years prior – were
discovered in this one meter wide and one
meter deep pit.
This begged the question, what were human
bones doing in Ben Franklin’s house?
Was one of our honored American heroes also
the United States’ first serial killer?
The short answer to that latter question is
no.
Mr. Franklin was a lot of things, but “murderer”
wasn’t one of them.
After the discovery, the “Friends of Ben”
called in Dr. Simon Hillson and his team from
London’s Institute of Archaeology at University
College London.
After a bit of research, and analyzing the
remains, they soon came to the conclusion
that the bones once belonged to William Hewson,
an anatomist pioneer and “father of hematology”
– the study of blood and blood diseases.
So how did the bones end up in Ben Franklin’s
basement?
While studying at the University of Edinburgh
in 1761/62 (the same university where Arthur
Conan Doyle served as a clerk for Joseph Bell
a little over hundred years later, with Bell
becoming one of the individuals the character
of Sherlock Holmes was based on), William
Hewson caught the attention of the Scottish
scientists and surgeons, the Hunter brothers
. The brothers eventually named Hewson as
an assistant and partner in their anatomy
school, allowing him to continue his study
of blood.
In a famed experiment in front of the Royal
Society in 1770, Hewson used the flow of mercury
through a turtle to show how blood moves through
the lymphatic system.
This earned him high praise, election into
the Royal Society and the Copley Medal (outstanding
achievement in the physical and biological
sciences).
It also gained him a friend and admirer in
Ben Franklin.
On July 10, 1770, Hewson married Mary Stevenson,
a female acquaintance of Franklin and the
daughter of Franklin’s landlady at 36 Craven.
Later that year, the Hunter brothers proposed
to break-up their partnership with Hewson.
According to PBS, it was because Hewson “no
longer lived in the school.”
Whatever the case, Hewson wanted ownership
over all the experiments he performed while
working there.
The Hunter brothers said no.
This created a rift between great scientists
that Franklin attempted to mediate.
Said Franklin at the time,
“I should think it no Trouble to hear their
Complaints if I could be of the least Use
in accommodating their Differences; but since
that was not likely, I could only wish as
I had a Regard for both, that they would go
on to the End of their Term as quietly as
possible, since that would be most to the
Credit of both.”
With the partnership now broken, Franklin
offered to let Hewson come live at 36 Craven
and open his own anatomy school there.
He accepted and his school officially opened
at Ben Franklin’s residence in September
of 1772.
Among the bones found in 1998 at 36 Craven
were the remains of fifteen different people,
adults and children.
They all showed dissection marks made by 18th
century surgical instruments.
A femur bone was found that was cut cleanly
through, probably used to demonstrate the
proper technique for amputation.
Skull fragments showed drill holes likely
made by a trepanning device, a pre-industrial
revolution practice (though, rarely, still
performed today) where holes were drilled
into the skull to relieve pressure on the
brain.
Additionally, excavators found remains of
several different kinds of animals, horses,
cows, pigs, and even a turtle spine.
It was clear that these remains were being
used for medical and scientific study, but
why didn’t Hewson properly dispose of them?
Why was he going to great lengths to hide
what he was doing?
And where did these human remains come from?
Throughout the Middle Ages and until late
16th century, dissections and autopsies were
completely illegal in England due to lack
of understanding of the medical necessity
combined with religious objections.
This gradually changed starting in the 17th
century, when autonomical theaters were set
up in many European cities for doctors and
students alike to learn about the human body.
These became giant spectacles and were hard
to gain entrance too.
During this time, according to the Einstein
College of Medicine in Bronx, New York, dissection
was “associated with great dishonor” and
would often be used as a deterrent against
committing serious crimes.
The Murder Act of 1752 allowed for capital
punishment as well as having this provision,
“the body so delivered to the said company
of Surgeons, shall be dissected and anatomized
by the said Surgeons, or such person as they
shall appoint for that purpose.”
In other words, dissection became part of
the sentence.
But dissection was only for those who had
already had their demise planned for them
by the state.
As anatomy schools grew in practice (the first
official one opened at Penn University in
1745 – the school founded by Ben Franklin),
the demand for cadavers rose.
There was no way the amount of executed convicted
criminals were going to match the need for
dissectable bodies.
So, doctors, scientists, and surgeons turned
to a less than savory practice – grave robbing.
In a few cases, the shortage of bodies for
medical professionals in Europe and America
even spurred some to commit murder in order
to sell the bodies to medical professionals.
While it is not proven that William Hewson
resorted to grave robbing (and he certainly
didn’t murder anyone), it seems likely considering
the range and amounts of bones he had that
he at least paid grave robbers for bodies,
if not did the deed himself.
In fact, the “Friends of Benjamin Franklin
House” speculate that Hewson’s bodies
came from “resurrectionists – bodysnatchers
who shipped their wares along the Thames under
cover of night.”
To dispose of the bodies somewhere besides
in a basement pit was to risk getting caught
for illegal dissection and possible grave
robbing.
All in the name of science.
As far as how involved Franklin was himself
in these “illegal dissections” and the
anatomy school, there is no evidence in either
direction.
It is even possible that Franklin had no idea
that anything technically criminal was being
done at the school in the house, though this
seems a bit of a stretch, given he knew the
work Hewson did and no doubt was well aware
of resurrectionist practices to supply medical
professionals with the bodies they needed
for their work.
That said, Franklin was in and out often and
even when he was in London, he sometimes stayed
at a different house owned by the same landlady.
So perhaps he at the least wasn’t ever present
for the transactions.
We’ll likely never know.
While the means with which Hewson acquired
at least some of the bodies were likely illegal,
the work he did was important.
From 1772 to his death two years later, William
Hewson made several discoveries related to
the human body.
He became the first person to observe lymphocytes’
production in the thymus and spleen.
He became the first to describe clearly the
three components of blood – red blood cells,
white blood cells, and plasma.
He correctly reported that red blood cells
were disk-shaped, unlike his contemporaries
who thought the cell was spherical.
Unfortunately, Hewson’s life met a tragic
ending.
He contracted septicaemia (ironically enough,
a severe blood infection) in 1774 from a dissection
wound and died.
As Franklin said in a letter to his wife,
“Our Family here is in great Distress.
Poor Mrs. Hewson has lost her Husband, and
Mrs. Stevenson her Son-in-law.
He died last Sunday Morning of a Fever which
baffled the Skill of our best Physicians.
He was an excellent young Man, ingenious,
industrious, useful, and belov’d by all
that knew him….He was just established in
a profitable growing Business, with the best
Prospects of bringing up his young Family
advantageously.”
Today, the “Benjamin Franklin House” on
36 Craven in London is open to the public
as a museum.
It is the last remaining home of the man himself.
William Hewson’s dissection bones are currently
on display in the Seminar room in the house.